appreciate you being with us here now
with more on all of these issues
pennsylvania senate candidate dr mehmet
oz is with us look i i know he's not
your patient i know you can't make an
official medical diagnosis
but when you see joe biden in the 80s
and 90s and
even 2008 12 16 you can see a very
different person today i i i he's a
shell of his former self to me and it's
to me a danger to the country and more
importantly the world
do you see it as a medical doctor
i'm concerned you know we do these town
halls all across the commonwealth of
pennsylvania and every single one that
comes up that our leaders should have
cognitive tests and there's a simple one
one president trump took the montreal
cognitive assessment by the way i put it
on dr oz.com so all the viewers now when
the show's done can go to it and just do
it yourself simple test remember five
words and then remember them in five
minutes or start right now cutting back
by sevens from a hundred simple tests
not difficult to do
president biden had a physical last
november his doctor o'connor did not
conduct this test or any other cognitive
test that we're aware of and yet as you
point out half of the american public
suspect that he's mentally unfit how do
you explain the forgetfulness the
outburst the handshakes into the air or
the quote the guys who are the
kleptocracies and by the way it's a
pretty brave move to put kleptocracy in
the prompter uh but these are you know
realities of of just observing what's
going on that we have to at least
address by asking for there's to be some
kind of cognitive test
most americans desire that you know i
i've been following your race very very
closely and i i did not know until this
race that your mom suffers from
alzheimer's it's it's i've no it's it's
a horrible horrible disease
um and it's become a factor you were
born in the u.s
like for example my four grandparents
came from ireland um i know i stand on
their shoulders and my parents shoulders
uh you were born in this country uh
because your parents had dual
citizenship you had it and
you often try to go back and offer as
much help to your mom as you can
and somehow that's become
an issue in this campaign which i find
particularly um
dishonest and i'm being kind and
charitable here
and
uh i want you to answer that question
because
why would that matter and why would
people question it's almost like a
question of your loyalty and as a friend
i
find it grossly offensive
it's my heritage i'm proud of it
pennsylvania in particular is a state
that prides people for religious freedom
and that's one of the reasons the state
was so unique when it was created this
has become a distraction it's not
relevant to who i am i love this country
dearly i've done the things for my mom i
love my mom i can love this country and
for that reason other senate candidates
have spoken out about some of these
attacks that have gone on again to
reinforce that as republicans this is
not what we stand for we're better than
this and for that reason i'm quite
confident that we'll get through this
but i you know in campaigns it gets ugly
sometimes i'm thankfully we're doing
well in our campaign i'm going to stay
focused on the people of this
commonwealth who desperately need the
help that tulsi grabber was speaking
about and these are issues that i'm not
going to be distracted by as i focus on
what pennsylvania desires
all right watching the race closely this
is a must-win seat uh dr oz great to see
you thank you for being with us hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else